Okay, willkommen zur heutigen Sitzung.
Ähm, im Zentrum der heutigen Sitzung steht ein interessanter Philosoph, nämlich Hoover Trifus,
und
ich kann Ihnen eine kurze Geschichte erzählen, also wurde dieses
Bild von mir aufgenommen.
Ich glaube, es war
2011 2012, es war eine Meisterklasse an der
Universität  aus München
und Wikipedia haben mich gefragt,
ob sie dieses Bild für ihren
Eintrag
über
Hubbard-Gewehre verwenden könnten, und ich habe zugestimmt, also ist es jetzt
auf all diesen Wikipedia-Einträgen in
allen verschiedenen Sprachen Englisch, sogar
Finnisch auf Hubbard-Gewehren, also ähm, das ist also meine
Referenz zu
seiner Person, denke ich  Es war eine wirklich
interessante Meisterklasse, es handelte sich um eine
neuere Forschung, also nicht um ai,
aber
dennoch war es wirklich interessant,
und
heute werden wir seinen Artikel diskutieren, der
eine Meinung im Vergleich zur Modellierung der
künstlichen Intelligenz des Gehirns zurück am
Verzweigungspunkt und als bildet  vielleicht ist dir
aufgefallen, dass dieser artikel nicht
nur von hubert rifus geschrieben wurde, sondern auch von seinem
bruder stuart treyfus, der ebenfalls
professor an der universität berkel ist  Hey
California
Ich glaube, er ist Professor für Ingenieurwesen,
also hat er diesen eher technischen Hintergrund
, aber Rifos hat sich schon immer
für diese
technischen Themen interessiert, aber versucht,
die Lücke zwischen
Technologie und Philosophie zu schließen, was meiner
Meinung nach eine wirklich interessante Aufgabe ist,
und er hat es
getan  Also von seinen frühen Anfängen
hier ist ein
Bild aus seinem sehr frühen Buch, das er im
Dezember 1960 geschrieben hat, aber offiziell ist
es von 1964 und
heißt Alchemie und künstliche
Intelligenz, also
war er schon sehr früh in seiner sehr frühen Phase mit diesen
Themen beschäftigt, ich meine, er hat dort unterrichtet  die
universität von berkeley in kalifornien, also das
silicon valley ist nicht so weit entfernt, es
ist irgendwie natürlich, sich mit diesen
themen zu beschäftigen, dann gibt es ein anderes buch, äh, das
bild, das ich wirklich ähm finde, das sagt, was
computer nicht können,
die grenzen der künstlichen intelligenz
von 1972
und das
wurde in einem anderen Buch veröffentlicht, das ziemlich
ähnlich, aber nicht dasselbe war, im Jahr 1900, 1979,
genannt, was Computer immer noch nicht können, eine
Kritik  ue der künstlichen Vernunft, also heißt es
hier nicht künstliche Intelligenz
wie in diesem vorherigen Buch, aber jetzt
heißt es künstliche Vernunft, also könnten
wir an diese
Begriffe Vernunft versus Intelligenz denken,
was ist der Grund dafür, es Vernunft
statt Intelligenz zu nennen,
und es gibt eine interessante Geschichte wie Sie
vielleicht auf wikipedia gelesen haben, also hoffte er 1967
,
drei jahre nach seinem
ähm buch über künstliche intelligenz,
dass rifus der erste mensch war, der
gegen das schachprogramm verlor, nämlich
gegen mac hack six,
und ich denke, das ist ziemlich lustig, weil
er so ein kritiker ist  von künstlicher
Intelligenz und er hat gegen
künstliche Intelligenz verloren, also könnten wir
diskutieren,
ob Mac Hack Six als
künstlich intelligent bezeichnet werden kann. Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob das für dieses
Computerprogramm in einem sehr frühen Stadium gilt, aber es ist
immer noch eine interessante Tatsache, dass
wir sagen müssen, was Rifus war  Er ist
wahrscheinlich kein sehr guter Schachspieler, aber ich
meine, er ist immer noch eine intelligente Person, also
wie man mit dieser Tatsache
umgeht, okay  Dies ist eine kleine
Geschichte zur Einführung
und jetzt, ähm,
ich denke, Ehre, Sie wollten uns auch
etwas über uber
triforce erzählen. Ja, ich
dachte in erster Linie,
um eine Art Verbindung zwischen dem,
was wir letzte Woche besprochen haben, vorzuschlagen, ähm, der
Kritik der
Forschung im Bereich der künstlichen Intelligenz  oder unsere starke
KI-Essenz von John Searle und Robert
Rifles Herangehensweise an die
Erforschung künstlicher Intelligenz.
Ich denke,
beide sind
in gewisser Weise grundlegende und
radikale Kritik
an einem bestimmten Verständnis von
künstlicher Intelligenz
und dem Forschungsprogramm der künstlichen
Intelligenz,
aber ich denke
in gewisser Weise  schon diese ruckelfolie
zeigt, dass es bei triforce anders ist,
nämlich
bei triforce ist künstliche
intelligenz thema
einer ausgedehnten und
intensiven auseinandersetzung mit diesem
forschungsprogramm mit der
jahrzehntelang andauernden forschung, die über drifus folgt
das Forschungsfeld
er kennt die
Entwicklung des Forschungsfeldes sehr gut  und
er revidiert immer wieder seinen eigenen ansatz seine
eigene kritik
an diesem forschungsfeld was passiert
und schreibt gleichzeitig ein
wenig die geschichte dieses
forschungsfeldes das in diesen jahrzehnten
und bis heute viele höhen und viele städte erlebt hat
viele heutage und viele ai-winter, wie
es oft genannt wird,
also ist er wirklich
viel
verflochtener. wir gehen viel mehr
auf die details der ai-forschung,
ihrer geschichte und ihrer unterschiedlichen ansätze ein,
und
was ich besonders faszinierend finde,
ist
der artikel, den wir heute besprochen
haben  Making a Mind versus Modeling the
Brain von 1988, weil diese Art von
Artikel
um
beweist wieder einmal,
dass um
treyfuse wirklich
eine Art tieferen Einblick in dieses
Forschungsprogramm in diesem
Forschungsfeld namens künstliche Intelligenz hat
und sehr genau weiß, was in
diesem Bereich passiert,
nämlich
1988 ist ihm in gewisser
Weise bewusst, dass etwas
auftaucht, dass etwas
kommt, was er ein neues Paradigma in
der Luft nennt  Forschungsfeld,
daher unterscheidet er hier
zwischen dem, was er einen klassischen
symbolischen symbolischen Ansatz der
künstlichen intelligenten Forschung nennt, und
einem anderen, der den Geist modelliert, der
mit
dem Konzept des Lernens verbunden ist, mit dem Konzept
der Anpassung, mit dem Konzept der
künstlichen neuronalen Netze und er sehr
Er
finde es in gewisser Weise erstaunlich, dass ein
Philosoph um 1988
sich dieser Art von Veränderung bewusst ist, die hier stattfindet,
sich bewusst ist,
dass dieses neue Paradigma eine Geschichte hat
, die bis in die 50er Jahre zurückreicht, aber
viele Jahrzehnte mehr oder weniger vergessen wurde
und genau diese Art von Herangehensweise
diskutiert ähm
[Musik]
hier im Gegensatz zu der
symbolischen klassischen Herangehensweise, die
später als gute altmodische
künstliche Intelligenz bezeichnet wurde, ist diese
Herangehensweise dieses neue Paradigma, wie er es
nennt, so weit verbreitet
und heute dominierend ist und Arbeit genannt wird, was heute
mit dem Schlüsselwort Deep Learning verbunden
ist,
also
finde ich es sehr
faszinierend,
dass Trifus  so viel beschäftigt
oder so viel
in Kontakt sagen wir
mit
dieser Art von Forschungsgebiet, dass er
wirklich beobachtet, was passiert, und
ein sehr gutes Verständnis für die
Entwicklung dieser Art von Forschungsgebiet zu haben scheint,
sogar in Bezug auf das, was jetzt passiert
und was möglich ist  der erfolgversprechendste
ansatz für die nächsten jahre
und das beweist meiner meinung nach eine ganz
andere form der konfrontation mit
diesem forschungsfeld als ähm,
dann hatten wir im fall von john cerl
transfer in
erster linie ai-forschung in
ganz wenigen publikationen einen
erweiterten artikel  in ein Buch, aber er hat
sich jahrzehntelang nicht mit solchen Themen
wie Taifune beschäftigt und ich denke wirklich,
der Text macht diese Art von
Unterschied wirklich deutlich
, aber ich denke, wir werden heute sehen
und dies hätte auch
in Bezug auf oder darüber diskutiert werden können  Anhand der
Schlussfolgerungen darüber, was Computer nicht können
oder was Computer immer noch nicht können, werden
wir sehen, dass es
in gewisser Weise einen gemeinsamen kritischen Punkt gibt
Mit Blick auf die klassische symbolische
ai ist dies eine spezifische Kritik am
Formalismus, man könnte
zu
dieser Art von Ansatz sagen
, dass es nicht ausreicht
, über Regeln oder die regelbasierten
Operationen
von bedeutungslosen Symbolen zu sprechen
, die im Mittelpunkt von John standen  cerds
hübsch
und es ist wieder im Zentrum
von Trifle Scripting, aber dennoch denke ich,
dass das Ziel der Kritik ein ganz
anderes ist,
weil
Triforce nicht so
etwas wie
einen ontologischen Unterschied zwischen den
kausalen Kräften
von so etwas wie einem Chip
oder irgendeiner Hardware von Computern anspricht
Gehirnkram
im menschlichen Gehirn, er interessiert sich nicht
für eine Frage wie diese, und das stand
im Fall von sehr im Fokus, also
interessiert ihn viel mehr, wie
, sagen wir, wie wir mit der Welt umgehen,
er interessiert sich viel mehr für
welche Art von  Beziehung, die
wir zur Welt haben oder hätten wir
zur Welt oder ob wir irgendeine
Beziehung zur Welt hätten, wenn wir
symbolische operative Maschinen als
comp  uters
und er argumentiert sehr stark,
dass wir, wenn wir Computer
wären, in gewisser Weise überhaupt keine Welt hätten
[Musik],
aber
diese Art, über eine Welt zu sprechen,
ist sehr philosophisch, sie hat eine
bestimmte philosophische Tradition im
Hintergrund,
hoffentlich wir  Ich werde heute die Zeit haben,
dies zu diskutieren, aber der grundlegende
Unterschied zwischen Searle und Trifles sollte meiner Meinung nach
im Voraus erwähnt werden
, nämlich
dass Trifuz daran interessiert ist, wie ein
Computer
und wie ein Mensch
wie ein symbolischer Computer oder ein
künstliches neuronales Netzwerk möglicherweise ist  wie
sie sich auf etwas beziehen könnten,
auf das sich ihre Berechnungen
beziehen, oder so etwas wie
Gleichgültigkeit gegenüber einem Menschen und seiner
Beziehung zur Welt,
und das ist ein ganz
anderer Punkt, als ich sagen würde,
aber das ist nur eine Behauptung,
es ist eine  Offene Frage zum Schluss, also werden
wir diese und viele andere
Fragen diskutieren und ich freue
mich sehr darauf.
Danke,
danke, Arnold, du hast
das q bereits erwähnt  heute zu diskutierende fragen
werde ich ihnen nur zeigen, also
haben wir wie immer einige schlüsselfragen ausgewählt
, die die themen der
jeweiligen
gruppen bestimmen, also ist die erste frage, wie die fahrer
die zwei unterschiedlichen
ansätze zur ai charakterisieren, nämlich den eher
symbolischen und den  die ganzheitlicheren
sagen
neuronale netzwerke, maschinelles lernen usw.,
die heute
sehr
viel diskutiert werden. die zweite frage ist,
was die technologischen und
philosophischen problemen beider
ansätze sind. ich fand es sehr interessant,
dass kreifos nicht nur
philosophische problemen dieser
jeweiligen ansätze diskutiert, sondern auch
technologische
fragen Ich meine, sein Bruder Stuart ist
Co-Autor dieses Artikels, aber ich
fand es trotzdem sehr interessant, dass er sich
für einen interdisziplinären Ansatz entschieden hat, ähm,
philosophischer und technologischer Ansatz
für KI, der das ganze Thema unseres
Seminars ist,
also drittens, warum Treiber  assoziieren die
philosophische Tradition des Rationalismus
mit der symbolischen Appro  ach to ai
und die vierte Frage, die ziemlich ähnlich ist,
warum Autofahrer die
philosophische Tradition der Phänomenologie
oder des Holismus mit dem
in der heutigen Diskussion vorherrschenden Gehirnmodellierungsansatz für ai verbinden,
und die letzte
abschließende Frage ist,
was die Herausforderungen beider
Ansätze für die Zukunft sind  Um der
menschlichen Intelligenz gerecht zu werden, sind dies die
fünf Fragen, die wir heute
diskutieren werden, und wir werden nun die
Aufzeichnung stoppen und fünf Breakout-
Sitzungen bilden,
um diese Fragen zu diskutieren